this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hey minimizers welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
ryan nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists ryan the world is
suffocating with shoulds
our culture has moralized everything
from clothing and consumption to
relationships and routines
society is swelling with scores of
well-meaning people
advising other people on what they are
supposed to do
you should
wake up early you should drink more
water you should watch less tv you
should read these books
you should go to college
you should get married
you should own a home you should eat
plant-based you should clean your room
you should improve your credit score
we are shooting all over ourselves
it's as if we're facing an advice
epidemic um
so we're going to talk about today you
know ryan i think some advice can be
helpful but as you often say all advice
is flawed
advice
and so on the minimal episode today this
episode i do want to talk about this
advice epidemic that we're in how it's
amplified by social media amplified by
righteousness
and on the maximum episode this week
we'll talk about how all advice is
flawed advice especially
unsolicited advice
and maybe there's a particular subset of
this epidemic right now where everyone
wants to give unsolicited advice but
maybe the problem is that we are asking
for advice
as well we're gonna talk about how we
can let go of all the shoulds that are
making us miserable on the maximum
episode this week over on patreon as
well also ryan i have some taboo shoulds
that i want to address with you
on the maximal episode we'll talk about
vaccines you should get vaccinated you
shouldn't get vaccinated we're going to
talk about all these
you should vote voting is one of these
shoulds that
gets heaped onto us
and also ooh i sense like a a fun
disagreement coming on oh i think so
with voting yes
yes well it depends on what you think we
should do
also fist fights
i punched someone for the first time in
20 years recently last month and i want
to talk about that but i'm going to save
that for patreon patreon.com the
minimalist every thursday we do a very
long maximal episode but today
on the minimal episode we're talking
about the advice epidemic
and ryan we've got some questions here
let's start with mike's question from
facebook let's do it
what possesses some people to insist
on giving others
unsolicited advice
man i'll tell you i think what's
happening today because of social media
like you said it is amplified
uh there's a lot of virtue signaling
going on
and it's it's funny because when i see
someone else give uh someone some
unsolicited advice usually
it's based from a judgment and what do
we say about judgments judgments are but
a mirror that reflect the insecurities
of the person who's doing the judging so
really the unsolicited advice it's not
saying here's what you should do
it's basically saying here's what i
should do yes and i'm going to project
that on you
because that makes me feel better about
the decisions i make for myself i saw a
thomas soul quote recently he said
politics is when you take your desires
and prescribe them to everyone else
and that's the same that's the should
thing as well right and so the virtue
signaling is a fascinating response to
this because
well virtues seem virtuous
right but when we think about what does
that even mean it starts to to mean well
this is good this is bad and and so the
judgment thing is what
you are wrong i am right and therefore i
must impress upon you i must convince
you or persuade you
that here is the right way to live
mike your question was fascinating to me
because i think if we even remove the
word unsolicited because i do want to
talk about that on the maximal episode
the unsolicited part we've got some
questions around that but if i were to
remove the word unsolicited what
possesses people to insist on giving
others advice maybe part of the problem
is we feel so compelled to simply give
advice because so many people are also
asking for
advice
without trying to what does that mean i
want to abdicate my own responsibility
of diving into this because if i say hey
ryan what should i eat who should i vote
for what should i do should i buy a home
should i go to college and you say yes
josh you should go to college and then
it doesn't work out for me stupid ryan
this is all his fault it's not my fault
it's his fault i did the wrong thing
and so i want to talk about right and
wrong and and should and shouldn't but i
want to do it through the lens of this
essay that i wrote a while ago this is
uh this came out i don't know maybe six
months ago it's called the advice
epidemic which is also the title of this
episode you'll put a link to this in the
show notes so you can read it as well
the urge can the urge to convince others
is overwhelming on the surface it
appears virtuous to help to instruct to
coach to guide to motivate giving advice
gives the impression of nobility as if
we have an obligation to ameliorate the
plight of the world
to assist people headed the wrong way
to point them
in the right direction
we are all middlemen in the middle of a
self-help epidemic
just look at social media overnight
experts espousing advice
you should wake up early you shouldn't
eat that you should embrace change you
shouldn't get anxious
what a weird sort of bit of advice there
right don't get anxious oh thanks that
helps right oh
why didn't i think of that right
so you shouldn't get anxious you should
change your habits you shouldn't wear
socks with sandals
but that one actually is true and kind
of yeah i got a point there although i
see all the kids now they're all wearing
the yeezy sandals with their socks
is it cool now danny
we've got our studio audience in the
house today ladies and gentlemen
[Laughter]
sean's the only one not applauding i'm a
little worried about him
ah there he goes
that you should applaud yourself today
oh yes yes podcast sean oh we got the
whole the whole studio audience here
jordan no more danny unknown podcast
sean alabama and immigrant
and uh we're all here today talking
about well
the advice epidemic back to this essay
here but really there is no should
there never was and without the sand
castle of shoulds all advice begins to
crumble in the wind each time we advise
someone it may feel like it's arising
from a place of love
but it's actually the ego saying
i know
what's best for you back to mike's
question from facebook what's the
ultimate source of this it's the ego
yeah it's the righteousness of the ego
it's the hubris of the ego saying hey
look
i've figured it out i was on clubhouse
last night doing some readings from our
new book love people use things and i
was talking to yaman who has called in
to the podcast before and we've talked
to him on several different occasions
but he and i he was saying look i feel
like i've figured out a few things in my
own life and it feels so good but why am
i so compelled now to advise
others
do you understand this and i was like
well
yeah i i too am plagued by
self-righteousness yaman
and this isn't self-righteous is bad or
good we hear these things and we start
making all of these sort of value judges
but it's understanding where is the
place from which this emanates
the desire to change other people yeah
well i think a lot of that has to do
with uh it feels good to help others you
know
so which actually is in a way is ego
driven too right because when i go to
the food kitchen
it is like this it you know ostensibly
it's the selfless act of like oh i'm
gonna help others but like i get a lot
out of that right so uh yeah i think it
feels good to help others so people are
they're looking for ways to help others
right because they're looking for ways
to what feel good yeah and if that's the
outcome nothing wrong with that in fact
i'm going to talk about the ego here in
a second how it can serve you in a way
and i've got a metaphor for you so i
know what's best for you the implication
of which is disconcerting
i am right you are wrong and if you
subordinate yourself to me
i will fix you
what a fascinating metaphor by the way
though the fixing right as though you
are a machine yeah and i'm the mechanic
and i will fix you now some advice or
how to's can be really helpful
especially in a mechanical sense if i
need to learn how to repair my bike
chain
right there are a bunch of really great
videos on youtube that will help me with
the the mechanics of that now if i want
to be the best bike builder in the world
there's no youtube video that's going to
help me accomplish that
anyway back to the text here i will fix
you
how is this loving there is no bigger
ego than that of the helper the helpful
man simply cannot help himself he feels
obligated to tear an eagle from the sky
to save it from falling to drag a
dolphin to the shore to rescue it from
drowning
this
is the opposite of helpful i know
because i've done it a thousand times
and for that i'm sorry
a thousand apologies my first
inclination is to delete it all every
exhortation recommendation suggestion
and opinion everything from the past 39
years
but
we cannot start over by erasing the past
we can only move forward in the
everlasting now
perhaps i developed an allergy to advice
because propagating it only feeds the
ego
now the ego
is not a bad thing
just like fire is not good or bad
it can warm you
or it can burn you um that's the point i
want to get across here it's not that if
we hear the ego and because we've
moralized everything oh ego bad right
ego lifts must be good right well no no
throw those out the window
with the shoulds take them all put them
in a trash can set them on fire
and realize that the ego might serve you
in other ways it might not serve you
just like that fire yeah and and if it
if you get too close to it well you
might get scorched yeah along the way
the desire to help isn't good or bad
either it appears for myriad reasons all
of which belong to the ego and
fortifying the ego is a surefire way to
decrease the peace now what's
fascinating about this ryan is
people value different things
and a lot of people don't value peace
and it's not that i'm better because i
do value people it's just something i've
recognized like i value alone time way
more than someone like you sure you
value time around people one isn't good
or bad one isn't better than the others
it's simply preference right you have a
preference for something some people
don't have a preference for peace i mean
i hear my daughter all the time ah this
is boring okay well she doesn't have a
preference for peace at as an
eight-year-old right yeah okay that's
fine and what i can do is i could talk
to her and i could say what oh you
should prefer peace
you should want to be more tranquil yeah
now i'm [ __ ] on her
right and what is she going to do with
that advice exactly i should prefer
peace like okay yeah then now what now
do i do yeah and then she said well how
do i get there well there is no getting
there it's already there within you
right because what if i said well the
way to get peace is you eat a hundred
blueberries four times a day right well
and then it doesn't work well now i've
failed her as well yeah returning to the
text here to advise is to put oneself on
a pedestal a plinth upon which no
sincere person rests it necessitates we
look down on others which
is an aberrant position for any human so
putting ourselves accidentally on a
pedestal that's what we're doing with
all of these this advice all of these
shoulds when i was talking to yaman last
night on clubhouse with with these i'm
doing these relationship with less rooms
i'm just practicing for the upcoming
tour that we have doing some readings
and q a
and i
you know it's funny he was at one point
he goes so you know what should i do
because i don't want to give advice
right like i've realized the sort of
folly or the the
the absurdity the illusion of my desire
to give this advice but now so what
should i do it says your mind you
realize you're asking for advice about
how not to give advice i i don't have
advice for you i have some observations
about my own experience and we can talk
about those things and how in a way
my own observations
can be much more helpful because i'm not
saying you should do this but if i say
here's the recipe of something that has
worked for me and when ryan you come in
and say here's something that has worked
for me yeah people can recognize oh that
may work for me or it may not yeah it's
like the packing party it's like i don't
think anyone should in fact i think most
people shouldn't
do a packing party
but yeah but me sharing it and saying
hey here's what here's what i got out of
it here are the lessons that i learned
um people can take it for what it is and
if there's an ingredient there that they
want to put into their life great yes
but yeah uh
i would say a lot of people uh shouldn't
do anything
yes yeah and and so what's fascinating
about that the packing party is a great
example of that's a how-to sort of thing
but it's much more about the
understanding that you got from it it
wasn't about tidying up your closet
organizing your sock drawer or whatever
it didn't make me happy it's not like
all of a sudden i had a packing party
and then at the end of it i was like oh
i have found eternal bliss right yeah it
was yeah if anything it made you
slightly more miserable in the moment
for several reasons one is you're like
god i have to unpack these things as i
need them like that's adding some
unnecessary friction it feels like but
from that friction came some
understanding
oh wow look at all these things i've got
all this excess stuff in my home eighty
percent of my things in my home i'm not
using them in fact they're getting in
the way of
my happiness my peace my tranquility my
desire to contribute whatever it is
these things are getting in the way of
that and that was true for you and the
reason this message resonates with so
many people it's not about the
decluttering of the closet that's only
one aspect of it it's like oh
the things are getting in the way of
blank and that blank is different for
almost everyone yeah but it's that
deeper understanding let me finish up
this essay here we're almost through it
so advice
no
i don't want to help you
i don't want to not help you either
i want to love you
love requires speaking the truth and
remaining neutral as to whether it quote
helps anyone if it helps that's fine if
not
that's fine too
the reception
is up to the recipient
the truth is exposed through honest
observation through seeking an awareness
through an examination of obstacles and
a deeper understanding of the way things
are
this let's pause on that for a moment
ryan we're talking about shoulds right
now the reason back to mike's question
why do we insist on this so much because
we're so discontented with the way
things are in our own life and our own
existence
and if i could just change these 43
things or these seven things or this one
thing this object a
then all of a sudden life would be grand
it would be wonderful
it should be that way because i'm so
discontented with reality i know in a
moment we're going to talk about
perfection and i want to bring that back
up again the end of this here to be
clear this is not a recommendation i
don't think you should do anything i'm
not arguing my point in this missive nor
am i urging you to comprehend my message
i don't hope to convince you of anything
the moment we try to convince someone
we have lost the plot to convince to
influence to prove oneself these are all
ribs lining the same umbrella the truth
does not require
the truth does not require persuasion
coaxing or coercion the it is the truth
whether you're convinced or not
as is love
we have a question from megan in
ballston
i live with my grandfather and while he
and i are both pretty minimalist in
ideals it must have skipped a generation
because his kids my aunt and uncles are
not and they have all of their stuff not
all of their stuff but a lot of their
stuff still at my grandfather's house do
you have any tips or suggestions on how
to navigate with them cleaning out the
house for both me and my grandfather's
sanity ryan what's your advice for megan
[Laughter]
i don't have any advice per se but i do
have some observations uh it sounds like
her aunt and uncles are using her
grandfather's place as a storage unit
and that is uh
well at least for for
megan and her grandfather it's
unacceptable
and maybe is it unacceptable for the
grandpa is the question i'm wondering it
sounds like it is through this message
yeah but what if he's not bothered with
that yeah it's worth asking
well
yeah yeah i mean there's there's a
couple of different ways you can feel
about it yes you could be
offended by it and look at it i can't
believe you know my kids are using my
house as storage
or maybe he thinks he's doing something
nice for them oh you know what i know
that there was a certain point where my
grandma she had downsized uh this is
years and years ago and i was probably
18 19 years old i'm over at her house
and she was throwing away a bunch of
stuff and like my knee-jerk reaction was
like grandma some of that stuff is
sentimental like hold on to it because
you know maybe like one day i want i
want some of that stuff and out of
kindness she was like yes you know what
i'll do that for you ryan i will hold on
to this stuff and i remember like 10
years after that she was like hey do you
want any of the stuff that you told me
to hold on to yet and i'm like no i'm
good
and she ended up throwing it away did
you forget about it in a way oh
absolutely most days it never even
crossed your mind that it was there
that's exactly right it only crossed
your mind when someone brings it up and
then it's like oh now i start the
clinging again i had already let go of
it in a way because i stopped thinking
over they stopped thinking maybe the unc
and uncle had stopped thinking about it
and they only start clinging to it again
when the threat of quote losing it yeah
they're losing something they've never
really had in the first place because
they're not they don't they clearly
don't need it yeah i think in this
situation megan
needs to explore uh everyone's
preferences right like that's where you
start like what how does a grandpa feel
we know how megan feels about it how
does her and uncle feel and then once
you kind of have the preferences laid
out laid out on the table then you can
start to create some boundaries with
your aunt and uncle with your
grandfather it's not just here's how it
needs to be uh it needs to be the way
that megan wants here's her advice to
her and uncle it's it's more about
working together to to see
how those preferences could come
together and create boundaries yeah yeah
the boundaries thing is really really
important in fact with the the new team
we have here we we sat down i'm gonna
talk about this on a patreon episode in
the future i think probably next week we
set up these 17 different boundaries
well why do we set up boundaries not
because i want to say no no no and but
these weren't even
proscriptions they're not saying don't
do this i'm saying hey here are some
things that we as a team and as
individuals
we may want to avoid these well why
because in a way if we don't have any
boundaries we don't have any freedom
right and right now what's happening is
the aunt and uncle are inadvertently
accidentally treading on megan's and
grandfather's freedom yeah or at least
megan's for sure right and part of this
has to do with our own expectations
if you have an expectation that they
don't dump their stuff at your house
then of course that stuff's going to
make you miserable if grandpa's
expectation is i really want to hold on
to this stuff for them because i feel as
though they need help then maybe it's
actually bringing him some sort of joy
in some roundabout way yeah so
ultimately as ryan said examining
especially examining those expectations
that'll take you a whole lot farther
than saying they should or they
shouldn't have the stuff
at grandpa's house although yeah megan
if you want to bring them to our boston
event we're getting ready to go on tour
it's called the love people use things
tour podcast shawn if you could reach
out and give her a few tickets if you
want to bring the aunt or uncle or maybe
even both or maybe your grandfather
would like to come as well
we're going to go to 20 different cities
we're starting in texas san antonio
houston dallas we'll be on the east
coast in boston and new york and uh dc
we're gonna be in man a bunch of
different places orlando and nashville
and atlanta and phoenix and denver off
top of my head here uh where else we're
gonna be oh salt lake city
vancouver toronto
la san francisco seattle
we're going to be all over the midwest
as well toronto and chicago
and columbus ohio back in our home state
our birth state the birthplace of
aviation and the minimalists
uh where else we're going to be we'll be
in minneapolis and a few other places as
well the minimalists.com tour if you
want to grab some tickets we're going to
give a live talk about minimalism do a
reading from our new book a live version
of the minimalist podcast as well plus
we'll answer a bunch of your questions
the minimalists.com
tour megan we will see you in boston
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions and comments to
937
yes indeed those texts go to both of our
phones we do respond to as many people
as we can and occasionally we respond to
folks here on the podcast now during the
lightning round so ryan and i do our
best to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media and thanks to our good
friend jessica social jess
you can find all of our minimal maxims
now at one place minimal maxims
we have a question here from holly how
do we critically evaluate all the
shoulds out there and take what works
for each of us
so it's so i i getting back to the
perfection thing i text you this morning
i'm like what about this minimal maxim
uh
what is it perfection is the enemy of
progress yes yeah and then i realized
that was winston churchill's quote so i
can't really claim it as my own you're
basically winston churchill when we
think about it right especially when i'm
at ramses with a cigar and a glass of
bourbon well and then you had texted
back and you were like oh this will be a
fun disagreement with which i don't know
how a disagreement can be fun but i'm
open to it we have fun disagreeing all
the time you know how it can be fun
especially we have tk coleman here oh
yeah the three of us like it's almost
like we disagree until it all sort of
melts into one agreement yeah well it's
funny how we all we agree on
like where it where it ends it's the
path to get there
we just take a bunch of different paths
but you had text me you were like well
if anything i think the opposite is true
yes that progress gets in the way of
perfection progress is the enemy of
perfection and the reason i tweet that
podcast sean
[Music]
um
the reason why i bring this up is
because holly's looking for this perfect
list of shoulds
there's no there's no such thing as a
perfect list of shoulds right but what
she's doing she's getting caught in this
analysis phase of like well i don't want
to do the wrong thing so i want to have
the perfect list of actions before i
actually take any actions
and and at that point that's where
that's where i thought of this quote oh
well this perfect list is getting in the
way of you taking action
right
right
and what i would say is that you're
taking action is getting in the way of
your perfection okay expound so so we're
already perfect this moment right now is
perfect it doesn't require any doing in
fact the doing is what ruins the sort of
perfection of the moment when a baby is
born it is perfect
and it becomes acculturated through
society through
other people through religion through
culture whatever it is
to
sort of ruin the perfection we cover up
everything that is perfect this moment
right now has everything that it
needs in this moment so right now the
eternal now is perfect and yet i'm not
saying well we don't do anything i'm
saying our volition is what ruins the
the perfectness
of the of the moment yeah um
i understand i and
uh i don't know what to say that because
to me it's like this
it's nuanced
it's like
let's define
um progress let's define perfection
because through your lens of perfection
and progress it makes sense to me but in
the same token i look at like our book
for example
is it perfect no of course not because
it requires all the doing but what if we
what if we
required it to be perfect before we
released it yes then then of course it's
never going to happen because perfect
already exists before the action exactly
and every action imperfects the moment
you could tweet that podcast
and and so let's get back to the
question here because here's where we do
agree ryan is there is not a critical
list or a a there's not a list of the
good shoulds and then a list of the bad
[ __ ] and that's that's really where
holly is right now hey what are the good
shoulds that i should do what are the
bad shoulds that i shouldn't do yeah no
that doesn't exist because these are all
perspectival situational personal
and even they're relative to the time
span as well the things that you that
were beneficial to you maybe that's the
way i would look at what is beneficial
to me not the shoulds what are the
things that are beneficial to you and
quite often
it has nothing to do with the doing your
packing party i think is the premier
example of this i know we already
brought it up once but the the fact had
nothing to do with the doing yeah in
fact it was much more about the
realization
that came
from that experiment from the pausing
from the not having the stuff
the realization there is so much more
important the insight is so much more
important than the list of actions that
you did because here's the thing let's
say you wrote out that packing party
here are the
100 steps of the packing party right
and you handed that to someone and they
just did those hundred steps they're not
going to experience the realization
right but there's a questioning that
that arises from the pause now that all
of a sudden
now you start to have a realization
around oh
all of these things that i've told
myself that holly has told herself that
i jfm has told himself i'm supposed to
do
it's all nonsense yeah it's interesting
though because without the actions of
packing my things up and unpacking them
as time went on for three weeks
i don't know if i would have gotten to
those realizations if it was if it
wasn't for
your marriage ending and your mother
passing away
you know would you have become a
minimalist i mean these are all
hypotheticals and what if hypothetical
questions didn't exist
yeah but here's the thing no there
it's it's just backwards from that so
you you've got it you're spot on it's
just that you had a realization first
before the packing party there's no way
you would have had a packing party
without the realization of oh i'm
miserable right now right right i guess
what i'm saying is is the so we're
talking about two different realizations
yes you're right the misery is what led
to the action so what you often say is
like if you could understand the problem
the how to kind of takes care of itself
so amen so in that situation that's
exact but then once i once the how to
was completed
i was able to have these other insights
exactly these other revelations i don't
know if i could have got there without
the how too
if that makes sense there was no how to
though well there literally wasn't you
had to make it up right
and and that's the point no one told you
ryan here's what you should do you
should have a packing party right in
fact if i would have come to you and
said hey ryan you should have a packing
party you would have been like get out
of here man what are you talking about
you should become a minimalist right
yeah and and so the reason those things
don't work but they worked for you it
had nothing to do with the how unfolded
on its own it's almost as though the
path unfurls in front of you
after the realization and of course what
does that do it leads to new
realizations which lead to new paths and
all of a sudden you start uncovering
what your values yeah and i know that's
the thing that you want to touch on with
this question is the values
understanding your values
it is not a it is also not a how-to
process right the the how to like the
packing party side of it the packing
things up and unpacking like that worked
for me to get to those realizations to
get to really the minimalists.com
because that's where the whole website
began was with with was with that story
um but i think what people are
looking for i think what you know holly
specifically is looking for she's like
well she's asking for advice how do i
sift through
all of these different how to's
i have no idea what's gonna work for
holly at the end of the day i have no
clue it's gonna work for her right and
so
when you look at things in through the
lens of good and bad what are the good
shoulds and the bad shows what's the
good advice and the bad advice
in fact on the maximum episode we're
gonna talk about someone has this
fascinating question it was amanda well
it's not really she said it's not really
an advice epidemic it's an unqualified
advice epidemic well who who now becomes
qualified to give the advice is it your
an advice degree right well i mean or is
it you know because all the people i
look up to are dead and they don't have
any degrees for the most part right
and the appeal to authority is tempting
but also at the same time it can blind
us if we just if we outsource you know
it's the same thing we talked about
earlier if i'm like well ryan he has a
college degree so i'm just gonna i'll
i'll defer to you on any business
decisions right because you have your
business degree right yeah and so you're
the expert on this i'm not i don't have
a business degree i defer to you and and
so now i'm i'm letting go of my own
personal responsibility my self-reliance
in a way outsourcing it
and when i do that
well then i'm not going to
i'm also outsourcing my understanding
mm-hmm and as soon as we do that yeah
we're in for a world of hurt yeah
there is yeah there is no
no one can help you understand no one
can help me see what my values truly
were until i went through that process
by myself bingo but that process
it worked for me yes yeah yeah it's
i understand where holly is right now
but getting back to the values piece of
it this is what i feel like is really
going to help holly it's like when you
understand what you truly value that is
where
life's paths start to become illuminated
the way i was talking to josh about it
before the podcast was the values is
kind of like this headlamp where like
now you can kind of like see in the dark
a little bit and have an idea of where
to go
but without understanding you know what
it is that you truly value holly like
you're
you could just try as many things as you
want but yeah you're
to me you're gonna that's a little bit
of a harder way to learn which by the
way if that's the way you want to learn
that's okay
um but it would be a little bit more
difficult uh walking around in the dark
then without a headlamp let's expand on
that real quick anthony demello talks
about how do you deal with the darkness
as you don't deal with you don't fight
it right quite often we try to fight the
evil the darkness whatever the bad in
life
you don't imagine trying to fight the
darkness
i did when i was a jehovah's witness
the the problem with fighting the
darkness is it actually
now it becomes more terrifying you're
panicking in the darkness um
well how do you fight to really fight
the darkness is by illuminate turning on
the light
the light eradicates the darkness and so
that's what you're talking about here
ryan your values
they turned on a dim light and it just
takes a little bit of light to remove
the darkness
altogether yeah one more thing on the
perfect the perfection thing i wrote
down this john steinbeck quote that a
lot of people use it's on these
successory posters and other places
and it's just like the winston churchill
quote i i disagree with the way this is
framed and i would flip it around so the
john steinbeck quote is now that you
don't have to be perfect
you can be good
well let me let me rephrase that for you
steinbeck now that you don't have to be
good
you can be perfect
because
we are imperfected by our desire to be
righteous to be good to oppose the bad
things but
man weren't we already born perfect
weren't we already born complete yeah
and everything else we do
incompletes us in a way so by letting go
of the shoulds
by letting go of the things you need to
do you must do
there are countless things you can do
there's a list of goods and so turning
those shoulds
into goods
is the best way to realize oh wow there
are infinite things i can do yeah that's
actually my pithy answer there are no
shoulds only could's totally ripped that
off from you but it's true amen well
ryan we got a bunch more to talk about
but first what do you got for us here
are some voicemail comments and insights
from our listeners check them out hi i'm
grace from the bay area and i just
wanted to make a comment on your
sustainable living episode so i started
my minimalism sustainability journey a
year ago as a sophomore in high school
and recently i've actually realized that
making my own beauty products has made a
positive impact on my life and my
self-care routine
everything is natural and it also builds
a nice relationship because it takes
more time and you'll use
less
products that
are maybe not useful in your routine
hi my name is lori i'm from the chicago
area
i wasn't able to come to the event in
chicago but i did listen to the podcast
of it
and i come from a long line of hoarders
even though i don't struggle with
accumulating stuff myself and i wanted
to talk to the woman who
had said she was having trouble getting
rid of things because she didn't have a
car
one thing i've noticed
is that many times people who struggle
with too many possessions
have plans specific plans for those
items you know you might hear someone
say um
i can't get rid of those doilies because
i'm giving them to aunt sally or you
know i'm keeping the paper towel tubes
because i'm going to bring them to the
local preschool for crafts
but that day never comes and you just
keep holding on to it
a side note there here is that we often
make plans for our things not just to
hold on to them longer but because we
attribute more value to those items than
they actually have that that would be a
whole other comment
so for people who struggle with stuff
i just recommend being really honest
with yourself about the plans you have
for those items they may sound
altruistic but it may just be like a
veiled way of excusing yourself to
continue to keep those items so i
recommend just pack it all up
donate it all to goodwill or the
federation army or have somebody come
and pick it up
and whoever's meant to have those items
will find them
and you can just let go of that
responsibility of feeling like you need
to find the perfect home for it and then
you won't be able to use logistics or
lack of time as an excuse to hold on to
things all right joe we got a bunch more
surprise questions this thursday over on
patreon that's the maximal episode on
the minimalist private podcast
patreon.com
the minimalist but first real quick for
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on in the life of the
minimalist ryan in about a week we have
a brand new month that is starting and
when a new month is approaching it's a
new opportunity to let go
we've had tens of thousands of people
play the 30-day minimalism game if you
saw our last film we also called it the
lesses now challenge and you can see
their photos of people letting go from
all over the world tens of thousands of
people but you can also download our
free minimalism game calendar it's over
on the resources page on our website if
you just go to theminimalists.com
click on resources at the top we have a
bunch of free resources over there
including this calendar you can print
out and it shows you how many things
you've gotten rid of throughout the
month so on day one you get rid of one
item day two you've got rid of two items
but then there's a tally okay now i've
gotten rid of three items day three
you've gotten rid of three more items
that day but six items total so forth
and so on you can play this game with
someone you love or with your arch
nemesis there are no should so you can
play it with whomever you'd like
it's a great point yeah the
the 30-day minimalism game the
minimalists.com
game you can read more about the game
there as well you can download the free
calendar on our website for our added
value this week i thought we would
listen to the new title track from the
killer's new album they come up with a
surprise album it is called pressure
machine
so let's give that a listen by the way
we have a bunch more surprise questions
this week like how can i learn to be
okay with the skin i'm in while also
wanting to lose weight well as a
formerly obese person i certainly
struggled with that and and we could
talk about that how do we address people
who insist on giving unsolicited
parenting advice
i deal with this one all the time
is my obsession with self-improvement
contributing to my misery yes well yes
but let's talk about why that is the
case and why we are almost all burdened
with that yeah plus we got a million
more questions for the minimalist we're
going to talk about some taboo shoulds
ryan and maybe we can agree to disagree
or we could just fight it out on the
maximal
and if you want to hear all that join us
on the minimalist private podcast this
week visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you also get access to our archives
there's hundreds of hours of minimalism
our ask the minimalist sessions are over
there we do a monthly ask the minimalist
session about 50 of them out there right
now and our patreon community thousands
of other people who support this podcast
and keep it 100
advertisement free by the way if you can
attend one of our tour stops if you're
one of our true fans or our vips over on
patreon you get access to all of our
live events we've had nine tours in the
past many of them have been filmed or
recorded access to all of those live
events and any of our upcoming live
events you'll have access to as well you
can follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimalists
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit the minimalists.com tour to find a
city near you if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list it's free
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple sunday emails whenever we
send those and if you leave here today
with just
one message let it be this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it
bye